make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with the boys yes we are the
boys vol 3 this one's kind of
interesting this this story is kind of
interesting much like we did with the
last two ones we're gonna do the regular
one here on YouTube we're gonna put the
uncensored one on on patreon so you guys
can check it out if you want to as
always it cost like a buck right so it's
not anything unruly or anything crazy
here's your the question that I have for
you guys too about the Rob core rings
the Rob port reins are currently
available on patreon people stop asking
for like whenever I would select the
winners people stopped responding so I
was like okay well I guess people don't
want them anymore but people seem to
have an interest in them now the issue
is that it's like 20 bucks a month
essentially for a chance to win one
because I couldn't really think of a
better way then to like mail them out
all the time and if I set up a store
they would be sold out like that
so maybe 20 bucks is like too much maybe
should be like 5 or 10 or something like
that I don't know let me know down in
the comments section that's something
you guys are interested in I can't
really think of a way to do it without
you know cuz I mean it cost me money to
get them so I mean I don't really want
to lose cash and like sitting them out
to you guys but I want you guys to be
able to have them give me some ideas
like let me know what you guys think but
anyway this one picks up with with the
with the whole thing with like tech
night right now tech night he's a
character that we haven't really seen
before just not being introduced
basically the problem and the funny
thing about this is that when Garth and
his first introduces in tech nights a
guy who just can't stop like having sex
with things basically and in like when
we're talking about things like we're
not just talking about people we're
talking about like everything right like
anything that seems to arouse him or
turns him on he can't stop like sleeping
with it and he gets kind of crazy
because like when he's talking to the
psychologist about this uh what he does
is kind of talk about how all this
really seemed to kick in and this all
basically happened when he was on his
superhero team called payback now he of
course is like a founding member of it
but they basically received a tip you
know out there in the middle of nowhere
that something was going down it turned
out not to be the case but when they
were on their way back there's one of
the guys there named mine droid he
started looking at his backside and he
was like it's a really amazing backside
and it immediately got him aroused and
turned him on and while that's not the
worst thing ever what is a problem here
is he tried to get with him while they
were flying you tried to get with the
guy of course he was picked off the team
and the result is that he's just kind of
in this rut now where like everything he
sees he wants to basically get with it's
funny at least you got a cracked me up
you pick up with Huey and you've
basically got Frenchy and and like the
girl again we don't really know her name
who are playing Monopoly on a clue board
now here's the thing is referred to as
cluedo and actually had to look it up I
had no idea cluedo was like maybe this
clue but I'm not sure so like I had to
look it up uh and it is clue and then I
found out they're doing a remake of Clue
why I do the original was amazing with
Tim Curry do that movies and movies
fantastic but he was kinda like why they
play Monopoly on a clue board and the
response of mother's milk is black
because they're just crazy like because
they're crazy that's why that's really
all there is to it the other cool thing
about this and really in response to the
big battle they had previously with the
teenage kicks is that Hughie's seemed
overwhelmed right because he couldn't
really differentiate between who is a
good guy and who is a bad guy in the
blink of an eye right and one of the
things that you're talking about when
you're talking about superheroes and
even those like the like the boys who
basically have enhanced abilities now
who were facing off against various
superheroes is that some move at super
speed some are super strong like some
have a combination of both or almost any
other kind of power and so you have to
be able to know on the fly who's a bad
guy and who's not and so what this means
is that Butcher actually ended up
getting ended up getting Huey this great
big black trenchcoat which is kind of a
cool thing it's pretty cool it's kind of
kind of officially inductee him into the
team and basically saying like anybody
that you see this not wearing this when
we're in the middle of a fight that's a
person you attacked it's pretty simple
and it's a pretty elegant way to kind of
clear any confusion that might be out
there in the midst of a heated battle
but from there you end up picking up a
tan in a comic book store and this is a
cool little moment because what you end
up having is kind of this revelation
from butcher in terms of comic books
serving as basically like the public eye
of superheroes right and it makes sense
you know comic books in in the real
world here comic books give us idealize
or fantasize examples of what
superheroes would be like in the world
of the boys the kind books are
essentially propaganda there's these
superheroes out there all these people
who have powers whether they've taken
compound V or not and then it's how
they're depicted by the world you know
how the world sees them and the world
sees them through the lens of a comic
book so it's basically like this
character did this and this character
did that and see they're great
superheroes and we have stories to model
them after right and so the reality is
anything but one of the things butcher
points out is that a lot of the
superheroes out there are in RK a lot of
them are lesbians a lot of them engage
in inappropriate acts with children some
of them actually go through and perform
surgical operations on themselves these
are people who aside from the gay and
lesbian community in the superhero group
are screwed up right like most everybody
else is screwed up in some form of
fashion now I'm not really it's it's
interesting to me that Garth Ennis would
look at the example of like of gays and
say like there's a problem with that I'm
not really sure that there is yeah I
don't really know why there would be an
issue with the gay superhero but what it
does seem to do is point to the idea
that in the world of the boys the United
States seems to be largely conservative
insofar as being
gay is not something that's really
accepted at the moment and so with that
being the case these superheroes who are
gay out there if they were to come out
and reveal that that it doesn't seem
like it would go too well but then you
get into the character of of swing-wing
and one of the things that really seems
to come with him and what we'll talk
about him here in a little bit but one
of the things that seems to go on with
him is this idea that swing-wing is a
character who is gay friendly but let's
talk about that here in a minute because
it kind of it's not really the nature of
his character it's really more of a
marketing ploy but again it gets kind of
cool because what they end up doing is
talking to a guy called the legend now
if I'm being honest here I feel like the
legend is a stand-in for like Stan Lee
or Jim shooter or or even like Julius
Schwartz at DC Comics or something like
that just kind of like the top guy
rather the guy who kind of seems to run
everything now the legend doesn't really
run the boys the legend seems to be like
this this big-time information broker
but what is up happening here is is you
end up having the legend who basically
tells Billy butcher and Huey that he has
a nephew named Steven Rubenstein who was
basically pushed off the building and
all all fingers really seemed to point
to the fact that it's swing-wing but
he's basically trying to figure out if
it's actually the case or not this
basically goes into like the marketing
side of things and again what you end up
learning here is that the marketing side
of swing-wing was that he was a gay
friendly superhero and it wasn't really
even because he was and we won't find
out whether or not he was until we get
to the end but it was basically like
bought American the company that Neal
runs the marketing side of the superhero
community basically going out and saying
this is gonna be your brand your brand
is that you're gay friendly superhero
you got to go forward accordingly
whether you want to or not that's the
best how your superhero functions that's
how it's gonna be be perceived by the
public that's the role you're going to
play it's intriguing there because when
you look at the nature of superheroes
you expect them to be characters to go
out and do the right thing because it's
what they do right have the perception
of Starlite with regards to like home
Lander and the other members you know a
train and so on the other superheroes
who are a part of the seven but the
reality is anything but and that's why
this this really seems to bring us down
the rabbit hole that nothing is really
what it seems to be and so from there
what you end up doing is picking up with
tech Knight and his Butler Thomas and
it's kind of crazy because what you end
up finding out here is that presumably
in the middle of the night Tech Knight
essentially tried to sleep with his
Butler but not in the traditional sense
insofar as he tried to like have sex
with his ear is basically what he tried
to do here ah
which is pretty screwed up and it's kind
of nuts right because like this guy is
in dire straits and you kind of can't
help but feel bad for right you kind of
can't help but feel bad for this guy
because I mean we don't really know what
to set all this off like we don't really
know what caused all this and so it kind
of sucks and it's kind of messed up but
his Butler basically bails of Cour
basically saying hey look you know my
job as your button is the butler for
your family for the last 37 years my job
is to tend to the needs of the family
but not in that way right so like your
secret stay safe with me but I know I
gotta go I gotta bounce out of this
place but then what it does is it moves
over to a to a bar called the Red
Rooster now here's the crazy thing here
is once actually getting to this gay bar
here we kind of seems to be a little
uncertain about it and like not really
big let me tell you something do gay
bars are fun do all like drag shows all
their fun as hell but any of you guys
have ever like if any of you guys have
never been to a drag show in your life
by do drag shows are hilarious like it's
it's fun if you're missing out like and
it's funny because it's like it's like
cosplay at a comic book convention right
like there's the ones who have cosplay
and it's like man that's amazing cosplay
then there's the ones who were like you
tried and that's basically it when it
comes when it comes to like drag queens
right when it comes to when it comes to
drag shows but the fact remains here
that they're getting into this bar what
the end up doing is talking to a guy
named Paul Drake now of course this guy
Paul Drake this bartender is together
they're talking to and of course his
boyfriend is sitting off to the side but
what they basically do is start asking
this guy questions like what can you
tell us about about about about Stephen
Rubenstein and what can you tell us
about swing-wing and the funny thing
about swing-wing is that we're previous
questions were asked by the cops are
kind of dismissed it right they were
like okay so was the death of a gay guy
who really cares that was the perception
of the cops but where you have like
Billy butcher and Hugh is showing up
here is given a lot more credence and
taking a lot more seriously and so
that's when questions start getting
asked about Stephen and swing-wing what
you end up learning is like like Paul
Drake's boyfriend Max was actually kind
of jealous of the character of I guess
of Stephen because Stephen was young and
he was attractive and would would seem
to come in here and draw the attention
of a lot of gay guys but also Dax was
afraid of the fact this Stephen was
gonna like run off with his boyfriend
like run off with Paul like I was gonna
leave Madrid say hey look this young
kids more attractive I'll see you when I
see a piece and that was gonna be the
end of it and so as a result you know it
kind of seems like like Stephen has or
max has something to hide we're not 100%
sure here but basically you're given
this this bit of information this
perception that with the character of
swing-wing he would constantly show up
to like different gay bars different
things like that and he would basically
help members of the gay community who
were struggling with tough hunts right
who were struggling with the idea that
they were being offended all the time or
people were like physically assaulting
him or whatever the case happened to be
but he basically sort of talked them to
talk to them and kind of assure them
that there was like better Shores out
there you know greener pastures so to
speak that in reality you know you just
kind of got to keep on keeping on but he
was really a shoulder
a lot of members of the gay community to
lean on and then he also brought tech
night a couple of times but at the end
of the day it was one of these things
where not a whole lot was known about
swing-wing
outside of the fact that he would just
go out there and he would perform these
acts and he would basically be a gay
friendly superhero and that was
essentially yet but from there you kind
of switch over to technical writing
technologist kinda like okay you know he
basically gets this phone call and the
idea was a tech night was supposed to be
the newest member of the seven right
until starlight got the job but what
he's basically told is that you know by
it by some some voice out there what
he's basically told is hey look we knew
you want to be part of the team
ultimately you were not chosen because
of like the history that that's gone on
here you try to bang mind roid when you
guys are flying back from that mission
because of all the stuff all this other
youth pulled off in terms of like your
inability to control yourself we decided
not to bring you in and and it's one of
these things where tech Knight takes it
as a personal affront that's that's when
things get kind of bonkers because
following that what you end up doing is
you end up having Billy butcher and
company who basically show up and and
start talking directly with tech Knight
himself now going down into the basement
this is what really freaks freaks tech
night out so bad is that essentially
Billy butcher and his experiences over
the years has come into contact with
various superheroes and he hasn't really
beat them all to a halt instead what he
has done is turned some of them into
informants and basically said like
you're going to provide me information
on the various superheroes who were out
there again which is very very smart and
so going down there and basically saying
hey about you know six months ago there
was this guy eagle the archer who
basically you know almost beat his
girlfriend to death beat her into a coma
I used this tactic on him and he's been
dumping me information so he walks down
there and he basically says daylight and
it turns all the lights on inside of a
tech Knights facility right so let's
kind of information he has as he knows
how these guys base of operations work
and that's when they start asking the
questions that's when they start getting
into tech night and basically saying
look what's going on here like like what
what can you tell us about swing-wing
and that's when tech night really kind
of seems to drop this this bit and
saying hey look there are a few times
you went to gay bars I wasn't really
digging it but it was part of his
character and and as far as I can tell
you know he's basically gay like he's a
gay guy is designed to kind of paint
this picture that like swing-wing wasn't
legitimately good dude and that really
seems to be the case right swing-wing
was like a legitimately great guy he was
a superhero going out there and and
being a superhero who is friendly for
the gay community for a group that kind
of felt ignored or or cashed off by the
larger part of society and so there
really doesn't seem to be a whole lot in
terms of the relation between swing-wing
and between Steven Rubin scheme because
we're legends told really butcher and
Huey
I think swing-wing was the one who
killed him the information doesn't
really seem to line up with that you
know why would swing wing
a member of the gate or Lisa a gay
superhero who was probed who was pro gay
in a superhero actions why would he in
turn kill a member of the gay community
like how would that work I mean now it's
entirely possible for any number of
reasons but trying to connect those dots
that's the difficult thing to do now
from there if this is when things get
really interesting right because from
there here we gets a package now when
when Billy butcher and Huey had shown up
to talk to Drake at the gay bar and his
boyfriend max these aliases this was
designed for the purpose of nobody
really being able to trace it back to
them because Billy butchers got a
reputation people know who Billy butcher
is and they know he's a guy to look out
for but with these aliases this phone is
basically sent to their address you know
for the alias of Huey and when Huey
basically looks at it it's match ended
up basically saying hey look there's so
a few things that we forgot Drake kinda
says the same thing and so max basically
starts spilling the beans and what max
says here is that we're swing-wing was
basically having like these kind of
meetings basically with members of the
homosexual community to kind of help
them get past the struggles they were
dealing with that because of the fact
that Steven Rubinstein was this young
attractive kid who was seemingly to make
passes at Etta at Drake that were max
was afraid of losing Drake and so as a
result he sent Steve after swing-wing
because he knew where swing-wing would
go when he was changing out of his
costume and changing back into his
regular clothes and of course it wasn't
his home and so he did this because of
the fact that he knew that Steve
Rubinstein adored the character of Swing
Lee it was you know he was a gay
superhero that that Steve Rubinstein
absolutely luck and so because that he
basically sent him out there and said
hey man you go do your thing go talk to
him or whatever and it was done for no
other reason then to not have to worry
about Steve hitting on Drake that was
basically the only reason why it was
done and so what you end up finding out
is that in addition to all of this that
you basically have the homo superheroes
what he's called either you basically
end up having like tech night who's
branded as as like a gay superhero now
again this is kind of an interesting
scenario here because the way that he's
depicted in the press's is not favorable
in the way that swing-wing is to pick it
but it's also because of the fact that
like he was basically branded as a guy
who tried to like rape the family but
that's basically how he's viewed here
and so because of the fact that he's
viewed in that way he's nude in an
inherently negative way because the
revelation of his sexuality came to
light through a negative act he's
basically branded in a negative light
and so because of the fact this
information is dumped out there what
we're told is that like the butler
revealed it right off the bat where the
butler was like hey look your secrets
are safe with me as soon as he was out
that door he went to the various presses
out there and said here's the story that
I have on a superhero who wants to pay
the most and basically set them all in a
bidding war and then ultimately sold it
to the highest bidder
being the New York Post which is kind of
a crazy thing there now the other thing
about this is that Huey is still
wrestling with the fact that he may have
to take a life right it's one of the
things that he's still struggling with
as being part of the boys now of course
like like knowing the Billy butcher has
done it and knowing that mother milk
seems to have done it is one of these
things were scum it's not really a rite
of passage like you're not really a
member of the boys until you kill
someone it's one of these things were
inevitably that scenario is going to
come along like something's going to
happen where everybody else is a
capacitated or he's out on his own and
the only way for him to continue living
is to take out a person who's trying to
bring apart and so it's one of these
things where he's not quite at that
point yet and Billy butcher basically
says hey look you got a tough enough
there's the world as you see it then the
world that'll benefit the world away it
really is right like you imagine this
fantasy where you don't really have to
do things like that but in our line of
work you have to no more being a child
no more being a little kid or anything
like that everybody around here pulls
their weight no exception and it's kind
of a cool point it's kind of a cool
thing right because that really is the
way it is I mean certainly not like
taking lives but like this perception of
the world the way we would like it to be
versus how it is like those are usually
two starkly different perceptions now
from there it goes into a discussion
between Billy butcher and Huey's showing
back up a tech night and basically
saying hey look so the information you
basically fed is about swing-wing is a
load of crap so give us the truth like
give us what's really going on that in
truth like swing-wing Wisma is not Agee
he's not a gay guy but he's not a gay
superhero he's a straight superhero and
so the question is like if that's the
case then what's going on that's when
you kind of get this revelation it was
bought Americans idea like that's his
that's his brand that's his bestest
propaganda piece like that's the role he
plays he plays a gay friendly superhero
and as far as the world is concerned
he's gay but the reality is that
swing-wing is not he's not gay at all
like he's completely straight and so
initially you have tech night he sort of
lashes out and begins to try to go and
attack the two of them and then of
course the girl was brought along by the
viability butcher and breaks this guy
down piece by piece and this is one of
the interesting things about her is so
far we haven't really seen what she does
like we've seen her kind of lose your
mind and lash out and so on but it sort
of kept off kept off off panel and
that's one of the things I enjoy about
this right you know the idea that like
she commits these acts and people get
torn apart but that's basically it it
was kind of a cool a cool element to see
in the in the TV show but at the same
time the TV show kind of gave me
something that I was looking for which
was what is she actually doing is she
just like super strong or just ripping
these guys apart or or what in the world
is going on it was good to get an answer
to that kind of question up but what is
up happening here is is tech night
basically says like myself and
swing-wing ended up having a
like we basically end up having this
this thing we're at work the
relationship between the two of us went
south because swing-wing was his
sidekick Eladio when he was younger
before he went on to become his own
superhero so it's kind of like Batman
and Robin basically and what you end up
finding out here is that there was this
character this this female superhero who
existed out there who went by the name
of Talon and Talon was basically this
this younger woman out there of course
with these claws and so on and so forth
but the way the tech night looks out of
the way he remembers it is it was really
more of a game right I mean they were
relatively young at the time
you know swing-wing was younger than he
is now Talon was a younger woman and
tech gnat himself was a younger man I
saw it was like it was really more of
like a game that we were basically
playing that really seemed to be going
on it was a cat-and-mouse game sometimes
she was a hero sometimes she was a
villain sometimes you know she fought
with us and against us you know
sometimes whatever the case was it was
it was really more like it really seemed
me more of like a romantic chase than
anything else because it was kind of
building up this sexual tension between
the three of them and it all really
seemed to come to a head a couple years
later when she shows up seemingly out of
nowhere and basically says hey look like
you should call LA do we should get
together you know we should kind of have
a have a haven't you know a kind of
reunion of sorts and when that happens
like you basically end up seeing that
like talent seduces both of them but
from there the question turns into we
have to go find swing-wing like we have
to go ask this guy directly like we have
to go figure out what's going on now in
all honesty Huey had kind of been
advocating this this approach for a
while but the reason why Billy butcher
didn't really do it is because they
basically be running up on a superhero
with no real evidence and is kind of
poking for a poking in and asking
questions and the truth is that they
don't know how deep the reaches of
swing-wing go and so it could very well
end up being that the boys are heading
to talk to somebody some some random
person out there somewhere and they're
all dead before they heard the sound
that killed him like that's that's
entirely possible so it's really Billy
Billy butcher playing it smart
trying not to send up a whole bunch of
flares and draw the attention of the
superhero community to him and what it
is that he's doing and with things like
this with basically murder mysteries it
takes a little bit of finesse ly you
can't just go in and just start doing
things and so as a result of that it's
kind of cool because what you get is
Huey just kind of taken the moment unto
himself really by force where you know
where they go in they start to start
talking to swing-wing they're like look
we need questions like we need answers
to what's going on with you and Steven
Rubens seemed like what happened between
the two of you and of course when he
basically starts to deny and refuses to
answer questions here we sort of begins
to lash out and it's just like you're
gonna tell you're gonna give us an
answer I'm gonna beat the absolute crap
out of you and of course we're fight
breaks out between himself and and and
Latium this basically goes into Huey
chasing them down and then Billy butcher
does kind of be like sorry man nothing I
can do uh you know the ladders broken so
you got to handle this one on your own
now in reality
year this is this is an important thing
to bear in mind it's one of the things
that again we've kind of mentioned here
is not all the superheroes who are out
there have powers swing-wing himself he
uses technology he doesn't really have
any kind of powers to speak up he can't
fly doesn't have celebrity or anything
like that and so it's basically
basically Huey fighting against a normal
guy and so where he starts lashing out
he also really just gives in and just
says okay fine this is the kind of game
that we play this is the game that I'll
play and just absolutely humble
swing-wing and so immediately he starts
spilling the beans and and he basically
just has like this this this immense
amount of hatred for the gay community
like he absolutely despises the gay
community seemingly because what he does
he basically says like somewhere along
the line like I was basically changing
into my costume on a rooftop and then
this kid shows up out of nowhere and
right off the bat I'm like oh god here
we go
I got to play this role we're talking
talking to this kid talking him down
about you know the struggles of being
gay all that kind of stuff you know and
like where I'm communicating with this
kid and he's basically saying there's a
guy out there that I'm in love with and
I'm afraid to say something because of
how he reacted so on and so forth that
swing-wing says just tell the guy how
you feel and that's exactly what Stephen
does Stephen says well it's you you're
the guy that I'm in love with and so
following that like he basically loses
his mind he grabs a kid pushes him off
the building and that's the end of
Stephen and by the reason why was
because he's just took an absolute
personal offence to it enough was enough
like it--is I basically popped off like
I had enough of this
and they said be like flipped his mind
and then push the kid off the rooftop ah
but again like like it really does kind
of come down to interpretation right so
that's one that's one of the reasons why
people will look at this and they'll
interpret it based on how they want to
see by based on what they want it to be
as opposed to what it might actually be
right it's the nature of interpreting at
interpreting things you know it's it's
just kind of left to your own to your
own biases and in what direction that
you that you want to lean it but it's
one of these cool things because
initially like you didn't really have
the response to beat this guy to death
but we would kind of expected that Billy
butcher would that he would like beat
this guy within an inch of his life but
that doesn't really seem to be the case
instead what Billy butcher does here is
use this guy as an informant and say
you're gonna go forward and you're gonna
continue to be a superhero on whatever
team you're gonna be on and from there
you're gonna dump us information on
everything that we meet if you don't
we're gonna reveal this to the world
we're gonna tell the world that you
killed a gay person and because of the
fact that you're supposed to be a gay
friendly superhero it will destroy your
brand and Vaught american will abandon
you like that and everything that you've
built it at this point will be gone
you'll be living penniless on the
streets and presumably the gay community
will start coming after you
which means your days are numbered and
so it's kind of crazy because we're
Hylian n and billy butcher having food
following that it's one of these things
where Billy's like
did you think I was being too lenient on
him and the responsive humor
surprisingly is no I don't think you
were like I think it's better to make
him live with his with his with his
crimes and then in turn have to be our
informant and really nothing else and
then just kind of go from there and so
it's a it's a it's a cool kind of
revelation on behalf of Huey because
he's really starting to see how this all
kind of comes together he's really
starting to understand the role that the
boys play not in so far as just going
out and punishing superheroes but in
trying to systematically bring them down
and do it in the most effective way
possible which is a combination of using
guerrilla warfare tactics and subterfuge
again it's probably one of the most
intelligent ways to do that without
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here -
comments explained make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the rod
for if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]